- I'm just saying,
Milk does the booty good.
- Really?
'Cause I got a good booty.
Oh, a drone.
- What the fuck?
I was just about
to smash, too.
[laughter and awed murmurs]
- Y'all dudes from Devry High
better stop
taking all our beezys.
- What can I say, ese?
Hoes love drones, holmes.
- Hey, man,
fuck Devry.
- Hey, fellas,
it's election season.
I hope I can
count on your vote.
- Fuck no.
Last time I voted,
Fantasia lost.
- Well, all righty.
all: [laughing]
- What kind of lame
would want to run
for Class President?
You know
he don't get no ass.
- Hey, Craigery,
love your feminist platform.
It would be so awesome
to have a women's history class.
- I think we need women's lit,
feminist science,
and CLAM,
Clitoris Awareness Month.
- I'd love to hear more.
We should do lunch.
- Yo, homey,
you need to make a move.
President Skidmark
'bout to beat you
to Cindy's ballot box.
- Excuse me, everybody,
I'd like to announce
my candidacy
for student body president.
Vote for me for HNIC.
[crowd cheers]
Ya'll hear that?
They love me.
Your boy's going to be
president real soon.
[crowd chanting]
Twerk, twerk, twerk, twerk!